welcome to the khan academy 2016 annual
report in the actual text of the report
we're going to go into a lot more detail
on the financials and other things but
i'm hoping here to give you an overview
big picture
2016 was a great year for khan academy
the impact has continued to grow in the
double-digit percentages and is
accelerating over 100 million people
used our platform last year people from
almost every country in the world and
they spent an aggregate of 5.6 billion
total minutes
so one of the areas that we've really
started to accelerate in 2016 was in
content development many people
associate khan academy with mathematics
but what we've really been investing in
is going beyond mathematics we really
want to cover all of the core academic
subjects that you consider to be part of
your education all the way through the
core of college and it's not just videos
we're doing a lot on practice and we're
doing a lot of written articles
2016 was a very big deal in terms of a
partnership with the college board
a few years ago they reached out to us
said we are going to revamp the sat and
as part of that we want to address at
least the perception of inequity that's
been around for decades and the reason
why they wanted to partner with khan
academy is traditional test prep was
associated with gaming and exam it
wasn't about real learning but they saw
that we were focused on filling in gaps
in students understanding so we launched
with the college board and what we've
seen over the course of the year is khan
academy is now used more than all of
paid test prep combined
and we're seeing that usage very broad
and very deep
and what's been even more exciting is
the psat which is taken in 10th or 11th
grade by 80 percent of american high
school students
in the past that was just a random
practice test you took but now it acts
as a diagnostic for khan academy you can
take your psat scores give permission to
khan academy and then khan academy
software knows your strengths and
weaknesses not just in math but in
reading and writing as well and can
immediately give you practice items that
are essentially weak point trading and
even more powerful we've been able to
follow students from that psat through
their work on khan academy to eventually
taking the sat to understand the
efficacy of this entire ecosystem
and what you see here on this slide some
of the preliminary results for
arguably the largest personalized
learning study ever conducted with over
300 000 students we saw that those who
prepared on khan academy for at least 20
hours saw twice the growth from the psat
to the sat than they would typically see
and this is just the beginning we're
working with the college board very
closely to do even further studies and
we've also seen that it doesn't stop at
20 hours the more time that students put
in practice the more gains we're seeing
another really exciting event in 2016 is
that duck duck moose became part of khan
academy duck duck moose i would argue
was the best early learning app company
out there
in 2016 the founding team said we would
rather see our work having a social
mission and reaching as many students as
possible especially those that are most
in need and so they became part of our
team in 2016 and going forward we're
going to be working on early learning
apps that holistically approach reading
writing mathematics starting at
pre-kindergarten and then taking
students through early elementary school
international continues to be a very big
part of khan academy roughly one third
of our usage is outside of the united
states
we have increased our focus on india
mexico and brazil and going forward
we're building tools and platforms to
allow each geography to be even more
localized to their specific needs
and going forward there's a lot of
exciting things what you see here is a
screenshot for the student
student-facing experience for
back-to-school 2017 where students can
tell khan academy what classes they're
taking what grade they're in and then
khan academy can personalize to them and
also have game mechanics so that the
students are motivated to move forward
you can see that right over here once
you get into a unit page
of course you see the videos you see the
practice items here but we are also
adding diagnostic quizzes and unit tests
as well
what you see here is our assignments
functionality where a teacher can assign
any piece of content on khan academy
this is a teacher assigning some
practice content they can assign to
particular students in a particular
class they can set a due date
they can then see a readout of which
students completed which assignments
and then they can see
which items gave the students the most
difficulty so that they can review it in
class the next day on top of all of this
we have a program called learnstorm
which is a learning challenge that
schools teachers students participate in
that celebrate the growth mindset the
more students can show grit perseverance
as they work through practice on khan
academy the more awards and recognition
the students their classrooms their
teachers and their schools will get
we've piloted in several geographies in
the past and 2017 is going to be the
first time that we do this on a
nationwide scale
so there's a lot going on at khan
academy what i just covered is really
just a sample of it but we're really
grateful for your support
we have a big mission a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and some
of you all have been with us for many
years when we were just starting in 2007
out of a walk-in closet this type of a
mission would have seemed frankly
delusional
but because of your support your
partnership all of the work that we've
been able to do together with
governments with teachers with students
it's no longer just a dream it's really
happening and the momentum that we've
built together in 2016 is continuing to
accelerate into 2017 and i expect is
going to accelerate in 2018 and beyond
so that as we look back in a decade or
two
we'll say how could we ever imagine a
world where there wasn't a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere